good morning believe nation today's
message is think for yourself over to
you Tyler the Creator we live in a
society where a lot of people are
followers and they can't you know make
their set opinions like I have friends
going to college for stuff that their
parents want them to go for and they're
not even happy here anything but they're
just trying to please them and in the
long run like I mean what's what's gonna
be there your parents your parents dying
you're just stuck there like paying debt
paying debt for something that you
didn't even want to learn in the first
place so I just try to tell people to
just think for themselves and they'll be
way happier alone so listen I think as
we grow up we are influenced by our
parents and our family and our friends
and the people around us right you think
the way your parents think you've got
the values that your parents have if you
think money is evil it's probably cuz
your parents thought money is evil if
you think money will solve everything
it's because your parents thought money
will solve everything you have the
mindset the values and beliefs of your
parents it's that's what it is that and
they did it out of love
like chances are they loved you you know
unless they didn't but they loved you
and it was all out of good intentions
and you now have their mindset great at
some point along your path you need to
break free and understand that this is
your life that you're living and not for
anybody else if you are in a job if you
are in a school class if you're taking
something only because somebody else
wants you to do it and you realize that
then it's on you right at some point you
need to break free and say this is my
life I want to live my version of my
life and not yours and it doesn't have
to be angry and aggressive right it
could come from a place of understanding
and if you look at some of the most
successful people in the world it came
from breaking free of what their parents
thought they should do right Michael
Dell started Dell computers his parents
wanted him to be a doctor he was a
doctor he went to school to be a doctor
he was starting his computer business on
the side and it started to do well and
he said to his parents listen let me
take the son
off let me not go Internet whatever you
know hospital let me just take the
summer off and focus on my business and
if it does well I'll keep running with
if it doesn't if I don't do well but
business tanks and I'll go back to
school and they agreed and the business
took off and he never went back and I'm
sure his parents are really proud of him
now for what he's done and it's the same
story over and over and over and over
and over again I think of the founder of
Sony Akio Morita eleven generations of
sake breweries and he was expected to
take over the business as the eldest son
and you look at Japanese culture being
super rigid right you have to follow the
structure it's family on or you need to
take over this business for 11
generations and he said no I want to
start my own tech company which led to
Sony which led to reshape in the
Japanese economy you know at some point
you need to decide that I'm taking
accountability for my life that I'm not
going to just listen to what other
people want for me and that you accept
the responsibility to that you claim the
responsibility for when things work out
and when they don't work out - if it
doesn't work out if that new business
doesn't work out you can't go blame your
parents you can't go blame the president
you can't go blame your lack of
resources it's on you taking that
personal accountability and yes you
could take feedback from other people
you can still listen to your parents or
friends or whoever it is if it helps you
along your path but at the end of the
day it's a powerful day when you decide
that you are in charge of your life you
and only you you're responsible for your
life you and only you you are
accountable for your actions
you and only you that's a powerful day
and I hope that day is coming soon for
you if it hasn't already happened so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
what was the hardest decision you ever
had to make to think for yourself as
opposed to somebody else's expectations
what was that decision that you had to
make leaving comments below curious to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events peso
now we're also looking at making the top
ten rules for success for tired of their
Creator here's a sneak peek at some of
the clips we're looking at I love to get
your feedback do you like it do not tell
me below when you think about catalogue
when you're going to do Terry bond the
album are you thinking now like man I
got so much out there that not that
you're in competition with yourself but
is very expectation is there is there a
pressure and and what's the problem
going in I just try to be better than
most I just try I just try to make the
music that I
it's like songs that I'm like damn I
will never make a song better than that
I will never make a song better than
Stevie Wonder's where were you when I
need you mmm-hmm so I always use that
like goddamn I have to make something
good like that and that's what pushes me
and the fact that I in my own head I
think I will never make something as
good as the song that I love will always
and that's something I say never grasp
it so I'll always push myself that's why
I don't know what the word potential
means this potential that's a gap that
mean that's a you stop that's a wall I
don't know what that means so I'll
always push myself harder and whether
people like it or not at least for me
I'm trying things and trying to be
better you know I think a lot of people
are forgetting that a lot of people
especially in rap it's either like for
the most part people are like where's
the deep lyrics what does he mean I
wanted any substance but a lot of things
are filling that's why even though I'm
not a fan of like a lot of like the
popular maybe trap music or whatever
it's all feeling this [ __ ] feels good so
what they saying is just a good feeling
and at least on my album every song is
like a photo for me every song is like a
moment it's a mood you know it's blow my
load is two minutes of just yeah I mean
even [ __ ] that's what it sounds like
that's the score for that every song for
me is a score for moments when it's
visual to you yeah I'm very so 2-seater
that's what it sounds like driving from
Hollywood to where I live during the
sunset in LA that's actually my car
noise I recorded on my
that's that's what it everything I'm
talking about on that song is real life
doing a hundred on the street but it's
okay cuz my car isn't stock my brakes
are good like Cherry Bomb the song the
crazy one that's what it sounds like
when I'm in my pitch and it sounds like
you know death camp sounds like that
Okada the last song sounds like that
moment when you're with someone that you
really like and time doesn't matter and
you're just enjoying company and you
just like we should just leave this
place and just never come back Schmucker
sounds like God and like God like I'm
the man like keep the O's sounds like
this this is keep the hose this is that
right there this [ __ ] right here
but skating down the street with that's
what keep the hole sounds like and my
verse on there is about knowing I could
lose all of this and I need to make sure
I'm focused and [ __ ] that's always in
the back of my mind [ __ ] young sounds
like being in a sunflower field that's
why I sent a video yeah the brown stains
what Q sounds like a Sherm that's what
PCP sounds like when the [ __ ] flips
like that's why is just chilling and
[ __ ] and out of nowhere it's that's
the feeling of it and a lot of people
are forgetting what filling is I only
wants deep lyrics or some [ __ ] that
is Phillip he's been successful for a
few years now how do you have you ever
had a regular job I worked at a I worked
at Starbucks and FedEx and oh my god was
it really bad Starbucks was cool because
I stole cheese danishes every day FedEx
was so depressing it was just the spirit
they're just older dudes like just
pushing boxes but okay with it and it
scared the living hell out of me so I
quit after a week in four days how long
did you work at Starbucks
two and a half years and this lady named
Cindy she was a new manager she hated on
me and she fired me and I hope she's
watching because I still hate her
[Applause]
I hate you see it send me aware of your
success I hope and I open her firing me
was the greatest moment of my life
wasn't really my change was free Wow how
did she do it she sit you down and say
it's not ago somebody one of the shift
managers warned me like ten minutes
before she fired me so I had nine
minutes to call my mom asking her what I
should do oh yeah it was tight I didn't
even like somebody who's like yo you
gettin fired in nine minutes boy what
did your mom tell you to do first she
was gone soon as thought she's gonna sue
Starbucks you figured out they did
nothing wrong okay that was nine minutes
that would saw I had about four minutes
left to figure out what to do so I
manned up and said alright I'll get
fired and I ate like three cheese danish
[Applause]